[Music]
ready to come work for Uncle Sam Secret
Service
Daddy get some sleep okay I need you
fresh tomorrow what happens tomorrow one
of my agents called in sick you're on
Air Force
One Dam I break this one in yes
sir
it's all yours General it's the
president sit back and enjoy the
rides let's first we have to take the pl
back remember kid only have one job
protect the
president Air Force One this Andrew's
Air Force based air traffic control
please acknowledge
over Air Force One come
in oh my
God we're still Gathering Intel we're
coordinating the search what survivers
for bodies adise
pres
hi you play the kin of agent my one in
at a
time now tell
me do think I'm
[Music]
lying yourself What's
happen sooner or later he will make a
mistake and it'll be the last mistake he
ever
[Music]
makes